I've come to Caltech because there is a
brand new gravitational wave discovery
let's go find out what it is can we talk
about the discovery around it yeah can i
I want to sit on one of my black holes
alright if you notice this one's big one
and the little one this one is a little
one yeah I I always feel like I'm the
most excited out of everybody really
yeah I because I'm excited when
nothing's happening cleaning some dust
off a piece of glass and it still seems
exciting so I think this is the key
piece of glass in our system and it was
just clean dust off of it how cool is
that on January 4th
just like a few hours after midnight
boom we got another signal much like the
first signal we found in September of
2015 and it's also well represented by
these black holes that were sitting on
one of the black holes had a mass of
about 30 solar masses and the other one
was about 20 and this one lasted longer
than the first one both because our
detectors are better at the lowest
frequencies and because the signal is
from black holes which are smaller so
they last longer and it's really
dramatic if you listen to the audio the
first signal that we got it's only
audible for about a tenth of a second
it's just like this but this new one
sounds like boom but it's a little bit
more drawn-out and it comes from farther
away it's the farthest black hole merger
that we've been able to detect so it's
at about 3 billion light years away
which means that signal the merger
actually happened 3 billion years ago
and the signals been propagating to us
for 3 billion years what's particularly
interesting in this merger are hints
that the two black holes weren't
spinning with the same orientation as
each other or as their orbit this
suggests that rather than forming out of
binary stars they formed separately and
later became entwined through orbital
dynamics this one really says ok we now
know that we're gonna be seeing a lot of
these things it's a it's a relief to
have another signal to know that
the universe is not just populated by
all tiny tiny black holes or by no black
holes if we improve our detector
sensitivity by say a factor of two or
three the rates will go up from you know
seeing one every month or every two
months to seeing one every day or every
week I would say it's very surprising
now that our first three signals came
from binary black hole mergers which
were pretty much a unexpected source as
of mid-2015 there's a working theory
it's kind of exotic that says that some
of the black holes were seeing our
primordial all right they weren't formed
through you know conventional supernova
explosions they were formed during the
Big Bang themselves and they could be a
part of Dark Matter a component of dark
matter all right so we may actually
determine after we get statistics on
lots and lots and lots of these you know
black hole mergers that were actually
seeing maybe a hint of dark matter it's
sort of scratching at the door of the
biggest mysteries that we have today in
cosmology in the past before there were
any signals people used to use this
phrase which I completely disagree with
and they would say you know if we don't
find any signals it will be even more
interesting than if we do I said no no
no no no no no lots of signals that's
what we want but now that we have a few
I'm feeling a little bit more complacent
and so I'd say we really expected to see
a lot of binary neutron stars and if we
don't well isn't that interesting it
means there's something going on you
know you have all the pieces we don't
know how neutron stars work we've seen
neutron stars using radio astronomy we
know they're out there we know that they
come together in binaries but why don't
we see their gravitational waves so it
could be something else happens to them
just before the final merger and there's
something in their evolutionary track
which goes off in a different direction
than what we expect and I think that
would actually be interesting I guess
I've become one of those people that
said if you don't see it then maybe it's
interesting because we learn something
you never know how many more signals we
have sitting in the can that we're not
telling you about can you say that again
I don't think so would you give me the
exclusive run it I would you know Derek
if I had secret signals you'd be the
first to know
[Music]
these lights are the first two tentacles
of a jellyfish I'm building and there's
a neural network which then drives this
little chip which modulates these lights
and it's going to use these sensors like
the proximity and the sound to figure
out if people are close to it and the
neural network is going to train itself
to flash the tentacle lights to make
people come closer to it